but
yeah i mean coming i mean obviously you
go from the battle world
where you're like a legend um
and then you you had the no no no record
i remember having that right on finals
yeah
yeah um but then there's like a whole
other wave of people who
just know you from being from young
money so
you and wayne and and the young money
situation
uh how like when did that start and how
did it initially happen because at the
time it was what just you and nicky they
were from the east coast
oh they were from new york it was me and
nikki but he was [ __ ] with corey guns
too
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah boy i mean i
don't know if guns i don't know if guns
i don't think he ever signed officially
but he
don't know if he was signed or whatever
yeah but i remember he had the milli
remix yeah yeah and he was [ __ ] with
guns
i feel like he was on the original yeah
yeah yeah guns
guns might have been around young money
before me okay
guns and nicki might have been around
young money before me but nothing was
really
solidified nikki was definitely around
around but me and guns was kind of like
wayne just [ __ ] with us he just liked
that rapping type [ __ ] but
yeah that was that that was that
situation i think around the time i
started [ __ ] with wayne might have
been like
2007. i want to say like 2007 because
this is the situation with me and wayne
i'm explaining this i had a song called
holla at a player
and i don't know if people knew or not
but i wasn't
assigned to universal no more this is
like when silvia roan came over and
everything changed like and
you know like i said i'm from the radio
era i'm from that era of the single and
all of this [ __ ] so i'm trying to just
keep my record going because i know i
don't got no deal no more right
right so i'm doing [ __ ] like
this is in 06 i'm doing [ __ ] like
recording myself taking the curses out
and texting dj enough or dj camilla or k
slay like or flex like yo i got this new
record
now this is usually coming from a
department yeah the right
record rep yeah now it's like you
sending me a [ __ ] directly well
all right cool we [ __ ] with you so yeah
just send it
and now i started getting radio play and
i'm like damn
i'm noticing i'm getting play like mick
show play twice a day you might get the
rush hour play you might get the traffic
out of
traffic jam play seven o'clock play you
know later on
somebody's come on at 12. i might have
heard my [ __ ] four or five times today i
got no deal
i'm in my mom's crib real [ __ ]
and i'm like i can't go on to another
record i'm smart enough to know that i
cannot go into another record i got
something going right now
so i hit wayne right
so i'm like uh i got this record
you know what i'm saying it's this
bubbling in new york right now if you
want to jump on it i sent it to you
i'm really just taking a shot in the
dark i don't i don't know if he's going
to get on this [ __ ] or not
but i had a record called bring it back
with jadakiss
and then i did a remix with wayne and
fab
wayne said come to the studio now now
shout out to fab shout out to kiss
you know what i'm saying granted they
was they busy
but wayne told me come to the studio
and did it that night and then charged
me nothing didn't
this is when he doing like 300 records
in a right so in my mind i'm like
i'm just taking i'm shooting from half
court
in a dark gym on all of these moves
right now i don't know what's going to
happen
send him the record he's sending the
record back next day
so my brother is like the super lil
wayne fan at this time
he like bro i heard that verse before
i'm like nah he just did this verse for
me last night
he said not bro i heard that verse but
if i'm gonna be real with you like he
didn't want to say it like that but he's
like he pulled the verse up like his
mixtape wheezy
all sorts of egg all on my face now so
now i'm faced with the decision do i act
like i do not know that this man said
this verse already
and still put this song out or can i
just hit him
and just be like yo i appreciate it but
i can't put this out you know blah blah
he was like oh my [ __ ] next day
sent me another verse back and said some
[ __ ] in the joint like mills had to tell
me stop recycling verses
and since i don't write it i recite it
in cursive i was like oh
that's personalized for me that ain't
like right
he just gave me a verse from some a
dedication mixtape that didn't come out
right right
right so now i'm like oh that shot you
took in the dark gym
you hit the rim on that [ __ ] like you
might just stay in this dark gym a
little more but just try to get closer
to where you hit the rim at
so now i'm like yo look man i ain't got
no situation i know you're doing the
young money [ __ ] you know i'm saying if
i could come play you some music he said
you got no deal call you right back
so i'm like oh i'm done on that verse
i'm like that versus a dub he's not i
don't got no budget i don't
he knows now i don't have money to give
him for the verse
he called me back with ted's on the
phone he's like when can you get on the
flight
he said but tell me this again you said
you ain't got no vert no deal right i
said nah
he said when can you get on a flight to
miami now i'm in harlem
mm-hmm i'm like i get on the flight
yesterday
he started laughing after that flight
i was young money until i wasn't young
money no more
yeah i mean so that was oh six that was
like oh that's around oh six
oh seven it was around it was right
before you know how right before car was
carter three was right before the car to
three when i got around
i remember the first time out he flew me
out after that conversation i went to
the hit factory
and when he walked in he started just
playing me a bunch of music and [ __ ]
and i remember he played lollipop i'll
never forget this [ __ ]
this is when i was like oh yeah i got to
step my [ __ ] up a whole lot like
that i'm a nice rapper that's a huge i
was like i'm a good rapper
he's a a great artist yeah and i have no
problem doing it
i have no problem with saying that
because wayne is my man i love wayne
unconditionally he showed me [ __ ]
that no other friend showed me no of a
homie no of a businessman or a ceo nor a
rapper he showed me
and he was hard on me with that [ __ ] too
but i learned a lot so
i'm like i'm like damn what the [ __ ] is
this but it sounded like the t-pain
t-pain was killing everything at this
time but now i'm
i know wayne from i don't know
and now it's like i'm like
i'm like damn how you do that [ __ ] like
now he playing me a bunch of [ __ ]
he played me got money now i had had to
beat forgot money from
playing skills or they had played me
like you know beating that game in the
beat
so i knew i was like oh i heard this
[ __ ] before all right let me just sit
here and listen to his version
i was like oh [ __ ] he got t-pain on it
that's that's the plan that they played
when they played
me the song like oh he i was like well i
wouldn't have never made this song like
this
right glad they didn't get his [ __ ] to
me like i'm so glad they didn't waste
this record with me because i wouldn't
have
never made this this you know what i'm
saying so
carter three wasn't out yet he was still
doing like college arenas
and [ __ ] like that yeah it wasn't like
the i am music toys
and then like a lot of the carter three
leaked
he was still performing a lot of the
leak [ __ ] he was still performing
were you around when the music leaked or
had it already been leaked i was
starting to come around
i was still like just doing my and like
i wasn't on universal yeah because i
just remember like
being up because i used to slang [ __ ] at
the swap meet that's why i got my name
so i remember just having
everything little wayne tastes like knew
that there was like carter three
[ __ ] leaks the droughts
and then there was like i mean obviously
before that
the squad up [ __ ] but like that that
like era like right before carter three
like the like 12 months prior when he
was just heating up this the mixtape
[ __ ] it was like
that's what really got wayne hot up top
i mean he was already hot since he was
[ __ ] 13 14. now but
i mean like like reinventing himself
from being like little wheezy to like
the fireman well no one took lil wayne
like serious no but he had to start
saying i'm the best rapper alive since
the best rapper retired
because he had the stuff he had to make
that statement and then he just
started and then i remember he performed
on the bt awards he performed gossip
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah stop hating on
the [ __ ] that
no remember that moment no hype man
because that ended up on like an ep
it wasn't even on his own it was it was
it was like it was a leaks it was a
little leak
like you didn't give a [ __ ] once i got
around him
that's what made me realize oh [ __ ] i
remember that i was like oh this is the
first single for carter three and then
uh
he didn't he was one of them type people
when songs leak him
he like like he called those dead homies
he was i mean yeah what he did with uh
because you know being the youngest dude
in
cash money i feel like as a rapper
there wasn't a lot of people with
credibility that probably took him
serious
until the first quarter when he started
popping his [ __ ]
that's that's around the time because
500 degrees was whatever
i mean i think the block is hot was dope
i think if you really were a cash money
fan you knew little wayne could rap
yeah but like people like like you said
like once that first carter came out i
remember working at best buy
man when that [ __ ] dropped that [ __ ] was
i remember the first time i heard being
uh bm junior mm-hmm he's got to put his
feet in the blades i ain't tripping
[ __ ] i play the corner like ripken
[ __ ] with the 40
i was like yeah he in a different world
but carter two
was was when because by this time i'm
deep in
rap i'm deep i'm an artist i don't have
my ups my downs i don't my
my high points my low points i read
credits i read magazines i want
people that go to school late when i'm
walking in the lunchroom with the source
magazine the double xl the blaze i might
have a vibe
right somebody blaze magazine yeah i
might have had [ __ ] the freestyles of
people get your tape decks ready last
night on dj clue the [ __ ] fire truck
right i was that type of kid so when i
heard carter two
i'm like oh [ __ ] this is the first time
i heard a wayne album with no mini fresh
production
and it was dope now i get to hear him
compare to everybody
else now now damn he rapping over the
heat makers who the [ __ ] are the runners
right you know what i'm saying so around
that time i got with wayne that [ __ ]
showed me a lot it was it
to bring it back full circle it was
around that time
right before carter three that's around
the time i got with young money